[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
قديما قالها الافارقه وداعا بونابرت باي
باي فرنسا واليوم يتكرر صدى هذه العباره
ولكن باللغه الروسيه
الدب الروسي يقطع رجل الديك الفرنسي من
افريقيا بلا رجعه قائلا وداعا يا احفاد
لويس فلم يعد لكم مكان في القاره السمراء
بعد اليوم ارحلوا اليوم بكرامتكم قبل ان
يذكر التاريخ نكستكم الاعلام الروسيه
ترفرف في النيجر وماكن يصرخ لقد جردنا
بوتين من كل شيء وابناء العم سام يهمسون
في اذن ماكرون علينا ان لا نعترف بالدور
الروسي بهذا الانتصار لنسحب لذه الانتصار
والنشوه والا سنصبح اضحوكه للعالم ما هو
سبب الانقلاب العسكري الذي حدث في النيجر
وما علاقه بوتين بطرد الغرب من
ولما تحاول امريكا انكار دور الدب الروسي
وتبرئته رغم اعتراف فاجنر بمسؤوليتها عن
الانقلاب وما مصير رئيس النيجر وبعد ان
طردت القوات الفرنسيه من مالي لتفر الى
النيجر اين ستذهب وقد بسط بوتين يده على
النيجر لتعرف اجابه كل تلك الاسئله تابع
الفيديو للنهايه هدوء ما قبل العاصفه منذ
عامين يصعد الرئيس محمد بزوم على راس
السلطه في النيجر البلاد تتحول الى ساحه
تخدم فرنسا خصوصا في عملياتها العسكريه
ولما لا فما زوم هو رجل فرنسا المطيع في
غرب افريقيا الشعب يتدمر من وجود احفاد
لويس اوقات الهدوء اصبحت قصيره جدا قائد
الحرس الرئاسي عمر شياني يبلغ بازو قائلا
لقد اصبحت ارضنا مرته عن الفرنسيين يدفنون
فيها نفاياتهم النوويه ويحولون الى ساحات
لعملياتهم العسكريه كل هذا لابد ان يتوقف
لن نسمح بان تحتلنا فرنسا مره اخرى
انت مخطئ الفرنسيون موجودون هنا لمهمه
معينه فقط شيان يصرخ سيدي الرئيس عليك ان
تطرد الفرنسيين من بلادنا والا ستكون
العواقب مؤلمه للجميع يرفض مره اخرى وقائد
الحرس يقول في نفسه انت الذي اخترته
سنطردك انت اولا ثم سنجعلهم يلحقون بك
يبدو ان وجود الفرنسيين بالنيجر اصبح
ثقيلا جدا على قلب شعبها وقرر قائد الحرس
هدم المعبد على راس الجميع فما الذي حدث
البراكين الشعبي
وكانه كالسمكه التي تتحرك في سكون دون ان
يشعر بها احد قام قائد الحرس عمر الشياني
ومعه مجموعه من معاويه باقتحام القصر
الرئاسي واحتجاز الرئيس محمد بازون ثم
قاموا باعتقال خمسه من كبار شخصيات
المقربه من الرئيس والغريب ان كل هذا تم
دون اطلاق رصاصه واحده العقيده عماد عبد
الرحمن يعلن استيلاء قوات الحرس على
السلطه واحتجاج الرئيس في مكان امن ويقول
في بيان نقطه ضده قررنا نحن قوات الدفاع
المجتمع في المجلس الوطني لحمايه الوطن ان
النظام الذي تعرفونه تم حل البرلمان
والحكومه بالكامل وحتى استقرار الوضع سيتم
فرض حظر تجوال من الساعه العاشره مساء حتى
الخامسه صباحا نزل البيان على راس الغرب
في عز ثلج الشتاء احفاد لويس يلطمون
خدودهم ويصرخون لقد فقدناه حليفنا الوحيد
المتبقي في منطقه الساحل وغرب افريقيا
والدب الروسي لم يرحمنا ماذا نفعل الان
ليرد عليهم ابناء العم سام في ياس ونحن
ماذا نفعل في مصيبتنا الكبرى نكاد نرى صف
العبره للقارات قادمه نحونا اظلام فرنسا
وتهديد امريكا
يرى محللون ان الدب الروسي سيستغل الوضع
الحالي ويقوم بادخال عناصر من قوات فاجنر
للسيطره على الاوضاع في النيجر ذلك البلد
الفقير الذي يعوم على بحر من اليورانيوم
ويعتبر مصدرا لاكثر من 70% من الكهربائي
التي تغذي محطات الطاقه النوويه في فرنسا
اي ان وضع بوتين يده على النيجر فذلك يعني
قطع شريان حياه باريس خصوصا وان رجل موسكو
القوي له سابقه قبل ذلك عندما استغل
انقلاب بوركينا فاسو العام الماضي وسيطر
عليها ليوجه صفعه قويه على وجه الغرب وهنا
الخبير الامريكي بيرو اليكس اذا نجح هذا
الانقلاب فان موسكو لن تضيع وقتا وستصبح
النيجر الدوله الا الحاديه عشره التي تقع
في قبضه بوتين بعد ان كانت تحت سيطره
الغرب وهذا ما يقلق واشنطن خصوصا وان
تاريخ بوتين حافل بمثل تلك الوثبات فكيف
رد بوتين على شكوك الغرب
رصاصه الرحمه
اريحوا انفسكم من تلك الشكوك نعم انه
اماما وجه لكم هذه الصفعه هكذا قالها الدب
الروسي علنا لو واشنطن واحفاد لويس فبحسب
موقع اعلنت مجموعه
عن ازاحه اخر حلفاء باريس من الحكم وقطع
يدي فرنسا من افريقيا بشكل نهائي ليس هذا
فحسبه بل وصل الامر لدرجه ان يقف الدب
الروسي مخرجا لسانه لابناء العم سام
واحفاد لويس ففي اليوم التالي للانقلاب
اقتحم الالاف من المتظاهرين المقر الرئاسي
في النيجر ومن هناك قاموا برفع علم روسيا
وهاتفوا باسمها علنا وكانهم يقولون لا
نريد الغرب مصاصي الثروات والدماء نريد
موسكو على الاقل كشركاء وليس كاحتلال يقول
هل خبراء العسكريون اذا اردت ان تحرم خصمك
من لذه الانتصار عليك بامرين اما ان تبتسم
في وجهه وانت في ذروه الالم او ان تضحض
انتصارات خصمك وهذا ما اختارته فرنسا
وامريكا فبرغم كل تلك الانتصارات فان
فرنسا وامريكا تنفيان اي دور روسي في هذا
الانقلاب لتقف المتحدثه باسم البيت الابيض
كريم وتقول حتى الان لم نرى اي مؤشرات تدل
على تورط روسي او تورط لمجموعه انقلاب
النيجر لتعنوا الاصوات يبدو ان ابناء
الامريكان قد سئموا من اعترافهم بالهزيمه
امام الدب الروسي
اكاد يسقط ارضا من هول الصدمه ويقول
كنا اسياد افريقيا حليبوا كان كله لنا حتى
جاءنا ذلك الشبح الروسي ووضع يده في كل
معاقلنا سلب منا مالي وبوركينا فاسو
وموزمبيق اوسط نفوذه في ليبيا في غمضه عين
واليوم يسلب منا النيجر اهم واخر معقلنا
لقد قطع يدنا من افريقيا وطردنا بلا رجعه
جردنا من كل شيء ماذا تريد بعد يا بوتين
هل تريد ان تجردنا من ملابسنا بعد ذلك لذا
فان الكثير من المحللين يرون ان نفي
واشنطن وباريس
هو امر طبيعي فالغرب يحاولون جاهدين حفظ
ماء وجههم امام العالم ويريدون اخفاء
سلسله هزائمهم المتتاليه امام الدب الروسي
باي طريقه حتى وان اضطروا لدفن رؤوسهم في
الرمال يبدو ان الدب الروسي اصبح كابوسا
مرعبا ليس لابناء العم سام فقط بل للغرب
كله وكان لسان حالهم يقول نخشى ان نفتح
الصنبور فينزل لنا منه بوتين وبعيدا عن كل
ما يحدث الان فالامر يوضح حقيقه مره لا
يمكن انكارها فبالماضي تصارعت القوى
العظمى على افريقيا وفي الحاضر اشتد هذا
الصراع يبدو ان القاره السمراء هي في
حقيقتها كنز ثمين الكل يعرف قيمته الا
سكانها دون مصر والجزائر والمغرب السؤال
لكم مشاهدينا هل سينجح الدب الروسي في
توجيه ضربه موجعه جديده وما هي الدوله
الافريقيه التي ستكون الهدف القادم لروسيا
بعد النيجر من الامريكان سيقلبون الطاوله
ويوقفون قطارات موسكو السريع اخبرونا في
صندوق التعليقات
[موسيقى]